[Music]
what do you want
you got some messages got one from dr
miller she wants to change your friday
therapy appointment
she better bring her a game because
you're gonna need it
i want to hear from the principal of the
wesley oaks elementary school rachel
thank you for your hair make up for the
music man production
kyle was great the quartet
no way
house my friend's son my son doesn't go
to
don't you touch my son
[Applause]
look there's a cop do you see him
it's okay it's gonna be okay he can help
us
okay
i'll just trust me and get his attention
officer hey officers
please help us
let's get started
[Music]
he can't hear you no more whoa
what do you mean well i think you know
no i don't i don't i don't what did you
do
what did you do well why don't you get
yourself to a tv
gonna be a lot of videos soon you put
him on the phone
you put him back on this goddamn phone
you put him back on this goddamn phone
no i can't do that
we have procedures all right we're on
something called a soft lockdown right
now
i'm the reason for that okay okay okay
that's my little brother okay
and this maniac's gonna hurt him even
worse if you don't go get my son and the
next
once again two minutes look that's him
texting me right now
let's see look look
same guy
i need you to go get my son
god damn it i need you to go get my son
[Music]
in these modern times the average driver
will spend over four years of their life
in a car and 80
of them at some point will experience
aggressive driving or more commonly
known as
road rage
rule number one if you find yourself in
this situation
you know what a courtesy tap is young
man sounds like this it's live
it's friendly sure that's what your mom
meant to do it's important
not to engage the other driver if you
apologize
i don't have anything to apologize for
rule number two remember your fellow
drivers may be going through personal
issues
affecting their mood or temperament my
invisible life
has been dismissed
retribution that's all i got left
yes troublesome people may be troubled
i'm pretty sure the guy in that truck's
following me he's road raging
he's just trying to scare you
rule number three once an altercation
has escalated
this is where your first lesson begins
things can take a
more unhinged turn it's okay it's gonna
be okay
that's where we are in this world today
we seem to develop inability to
apologize
to anyone for anything
but you can learn
just remember be safe out there
[Applause]
[Music]
you